foreign
with the man
the man
oh okay okay
you know I have to say just like getting
to know you guys a little more you all
bring a really cool personality and
value to this whole group dynamic have
to say like everyone has like this
really essential quality I I I'm just
realizing more Rush Hour like I really
feel like Allah has connected three
completely unique realities that
somehow in such a such an awesome way
yeah I mean and I think everyone has
quality that you have this like
technical quality that pushes us to do
things right uh you you bring it you
calm us down a little bit you know with
all the astrologers
[Music]
and uh and you know Rami also has a very
it's it's sort of you both have a very
calming personality to things like that
but Rami I don't know how to describe it
Romi just glues it together I feel the
crime is the glue really I think so it
feels that way to me but hey this is
just an outsider looking at it in this
as well too man because there's so many
people out there who you know might
mistakenly but I and has it on you
mistaken them you know not not even on
purpose just you know out of love you
know that's what happened to the
companions or the companion so they went
out to like swim and one of the
companions took his shirt off right and
the other companion looked at it and
just said wow this your skin is like of
like a beautiful like you know virgin
you know girl like it's just so soft and
simple and immediately just fell to the
floor right and when they brought to the
bathroom he said why would you do this
to your brother right shouldn't you say
Barack Allah right so even though
someone might be watching this you know
I love the three Muslims right but
perhaps they're not saying so may Allah
do that may Allah allow us to you know
do the ascad and stuff like that to do
that shout out to all you guys make sure
you guys do you guys as well too you
know we gotta stay safe comment down
below let us know if you guys figure out
the cars every day if that's something
you want to work on inshallah and yeah
that's going to always give you a lot in
the car that I had to stop the
conversation and say bro you gotta make
this podcast
yeah it was about like just the overall
social media game and because it's
definitely a game it's there's there's a
way to play this thing you know and
burnouts that are associated to this you
know people's failed marriages
Associated as well yeah bro uh failed
managers social media for sure and um
I don't know it's it's definitely
something beneficial but at the same
time if you're not using it correctly
it's trapped from the devil bro it's
really a devil's trap and I'm sure we
have all been on one of those rabbit
holes in either Tick Tock or on YouTube
or something or Instagram or Facebook
stuff or you just keep going on and on
and on but you know burnouts are real or
unsure when it comes to
this or like
school or whatever very much real yeah
so what is a burnout what does it look
like
to tell you something no no outside of
purpose Leave myself out you know don't
want to be burping on the on the nice
microphones
um or not how would you describe it
I think a burnout is a period of
exhaustion and fatigue that follows when
you don't take time to like recharge
your battery and this could be social
Journal work burn out even sometimes run
out from stuff like school or making
money or even God forbid the team bro
there's so many people burn up because
they set these goals which are really
good but it's kind of over ambitious and
they try to like go on 10. you know
there were there were men that came to
the club so on and they were they were
saying that you know because you do this
I'm gonna do this so for example I'm not
gonna pray uh or I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna take breaks from playing I'm gonna
pray all night I think another one said
I'm gonna never sleep with my wife and
the other one said I'm gonna never uh
I'm just gonna fast forever and break my
fast EST one said no that's that's
extreme I do these things you know when
it's time I recharge
and you know pray like when it's time
not like only I believe I'm perfect No
so at the end of the day like we need to
take time off so even things from the
team some people experience burnout
because they just don't know when to
like take time off step back religious
burnouts you being coming into Islam and
you know what when a lot of times we are
excited about the demon you know we
might go all in you know I'm sure you've
had moments like that do you feel like
you can never think that you had a
religious or spiritual life burner
that's spiritual burnout but I guess
religious burnouts huh you know I've had
it man and it's it's basically what you
said you get all these others we used to
get hyped you're like oh all right let
me do this and do this let me do this
and then like when you start doing it
you
Yeah you mentioned the best of these are
those that are small
or consistent
I think that's most important part I
don't know all the entire choice but
like with Islam I like to learn to take
it away because you know I want to grow
up it's not the best of Deeds but I love
those
I want to say the best everyone's gonna
take a step back just doing micro little
Deeds my friend said no no it's it's a
consistent age right because I remember
I was watching this uh thing on
National Geographic or something like
that and
um they were talking about the Grand
Canyon you know the Grand Canyon itself
too before I thought the Grand Canyon
was like a meteor had hit it or not sure
that hit it before right I didn't know
and when I learned about it there's a
Kenya it's like a whole thing right and
I found out that the Colorado River cut
through that Canyon should that water
that you see underneath this Colorado
River and uh it created through time
through millions of years of just
passing over and over and over again it
created a whole Canyon in between them
right and the reason I'm sharing this is
because those deeds that are small but
consistent creates a long lasting impact
it might not happen immediately right
like those games when you talk about
working I know two I'm sitting next to
our Channel between uh personal trainers
like you'll see this like you're not
always going to see those results
immediately right but the consistency
behind it is what makes it good and I
think that burnouts happen when you try
to do more than you were able to handle
right you have to build the type of
stamina type of muscle memory or
something where you're able to sustain
it because the way you're going is
unsustainable you get me like if you're
you're driving with the highest RPMs
your engine can blow out here you know
that sort of essentially I consider a
burnout like you are putting way too
much pressure on something when the
engine's still cold and you have to you
have to build it up if you think there's
any times where the prophetamine saw
some like talked about perhaps you could
like find something on the
chronographers girl but it talks about
like extremism or yeah yeah so correct
me from wrong I recall the headings
where he said do not take basically do
not take your relationship extremes yeah
and also there's a Hadith it's a very
beautiful Hadith I think of of hanza but
I do a lot of money or he I think he
talked about this recently as well he
and other companions were with the
prophet
and they were talking about jahanda and
Jannah is that it the comments as if
they could see it in front of them they
described it so much it's like they
could see it that's how he reported it
then later they left hands that I never
see I left I went to my family my wife
my kids my work I played I blocked I you
know had fun and I forgot I couldn't see
them anymore and he went to Abu Bakr and
he's like yeah
he's like why what happened he's like
you know I was with the person it was as
if I could see heaven and hell and I
went I laughed I played it I forgot
about it I can't see anyone he's like
he's like well the same thing just
happened to me so he was the processor
and he told him about this he said the
same exact thing he narrated it across
the time he already said that he said
your hands are that there's a time for
this and there's a time for that wow
very effective there's a time for this
yeah there's time for you know they can
remember Allah you know remembering
um the truth the reality the day of
judgment death even right remember often
the destroy of all pleasures death so on
and so forth and there's a time to be
with your family to relax there's even
one scholar to forget who it was but he
he actually emphasized uh taking a break
and taking time to enjoy yourself he
narrated actually
um he saw these two men carrying a log
or having a lot of Surgeons heavy
lifting and to kind of entertain
themselves one would say a line of
poetry and then the other one would say
a lot of poetry in response trying to
keep the same Rhythm you know and flow
going back and forth so the scholar
narrates the eye pause and stops you
listen to them for entertainment so it's
actually important if you want to keep
your Dean you're a man alive you need
some kind of break for that and one
thing I want to highlight is we kind of
spoke about burning out as if it's in
one regard like you burn out with work
or you burn out religion my experience
burning hours with everything with
religion with school with work with
family and departments with everything
it's like everything together as a
policy can't do all this anymore and it
goes together with that triangle that
you spoke about when you feel bad you do
bad and you think that you know because
the burnouts don't just affect one part
of your life it's everything you know
you don't separate yourself from work
like if you're having a bad day at work
you tend to bring that home right you're
having a bad day at school you tend to
bring that home you try to it tends to
bleed into every aspect of Our Lives as
well too because we can't just separate
ourselves because you know we we're all
one within within those systems but
eventually in your point there's so many
perhaps failed marriages because the
same thing happens as well too like the
like the husband is bringing home the
work you know they bring home that
stress they bring home and think that's
all work work we're going some people
are so obsessed with money that they
just want to work and they will say I'm
working so I can provide my family for
the best and they will shaytan has trick
them to believe that they're working so
that your family can have the best
lifestyle but you never spend time with
your family believe me your children and
your wife want to see you home they want
to see you spend time with you more than
the money going on trips and holidays
and all that sort of stuff so you can
make this excuse about like oh I want to
work I want to work so I can provide for
my family but to provide your family
with this lifestyle but the truth is
that that work is keeping you away from
your family so there needs to be a type
of balance it can strike between them if
you're a you know a student sometimes
all you can think about studying all the
time you know there's some people who
are just like studious about like they
just study studies you ask them a lot of
study you know like seriously like
they're you know study around me he
looked like you had a really good study
habits instead of the team so he looks
like right don't be look at those like a
little worm like a little Bookworm over
here I think so yeah you look like you
look like you have some good stuff I was
good with it there you go all right
there we go and you know a lot of times
even though it's probably listening to
us as well they don't realize this but
when you're burning out you can't
perform your best you know you're just
not able to perform your best the way I
tend to like when I was studying when I
learned how to say because you have to
learn how to do these things right it
doesn't just come to you you have to
learn how to study I didn't know that I
thought that you know
that's it right no but there's actual
ways to study
um as a lot of people may or may not
noticed but I told you guys I'm
professionally a school teacher right so
you can imagine like I'm doing all this
right what does a school teacher have to
do right we have homework right we have
to create we have to do like think about
like all the responsibilities the
teacher has I have those same
responsibilities right and I have 120
people who expect to see a lesson every
single day think about that bro 120
little humans wanting a lesson every
single day and I have to deal with all
these types of personalities and all
that stuff burnouts happening all the
times I'm sure that there's teachers
listen they know teachers get burned out
all the time the reason I'm sharing is
you is like I learned when you have a
lesson plan and do all these things is
that
and once upon a time I would say okay
I'm gonna come home and for the weekend
I'm gonna grade I'm gonna do every
single thing right Saturday comes I'm
gonna do it on Saturday
so Saturday comes and I keep delaying it
I'll do it later in an hour in two hours
whatever okay after the Lord after this
and I end up never doing it I end up not
doing a single thing okay then Sunday
comes and all this dread starts coming
with it like oh damn it's due tomorrow I
didn't do nothing I didn't I broke my
promise and this burnout effect is
having effects on everyone else now I'm
taking it out my wife my kids my family
my mom you know sometimes we speak mean
to our parents because we're dealing
with personal things we just take no no
it's not for Allah you know so your
whole family gets impacted by these
things
what I learned to do instead was set
timers that helps me out set timers so I
would set a 45 minute timer and I would
do nothing but that task for 45 minutes
and one and once that timer is on
there's no other tabs open I'm only
doing that and so how do I found my
focus was just so like
spot on right once that timer went off
stopped where I was and I'm able to
reward myself and do whatever I want to
do before another period of time and
then I could spend another 45 minutes
and do as well too that's how I could
study that's how I can work for anyone
as well too
um but that was my personal experience
with it and because burnouts are reality
so
we need to talk about this because
burning out bringing this whole stuff
home from work it's important it makes
it not present and there's other side
social media bro people are so they're
in the same room but they're just on
each other's phones and they're not
really impressive so let's talk about
the second one bro this this whole thing
on social media a lot of people are
commenting bro there's a lot of good
there's a lot of share that can come out
of it you know giving that word all this
but there's there's a dark side so
there's an extreme end of it where it's
no longer just doing good it's a cute
little hope bro and we were talking in
the car about the algorithm right
there's people there's nerds in like you
know in these cubicles
literally analyzing what you do what you
watch how long you watch when you skip
what you like to do your phone somehow
if you knew the analytics and Tick Tock
story bro it knows you better than you
know yourself
so one thing I'd like to say I'd like to
tell you about something
about narration but I actually love
myself where companion comes into which
are too hard to learn right so she
teaches it
about the lesson teaches them to Hadith
whatever we know this story but I think
it's important to see it in this regard
so a command comes to uh and she you
know asking her to teach him something
and she teaches him Hadith okay the next
day that same person comes back and asks
for another one she asked a simple
question well did you apply it did you
apply what you learned he said no she
said go back go back and learn okay okay
so let me ask you out there listeners or
you guys as well to just want to know
okay when you've been binge watching a
bunch of Mufti Mech videos
what have you applied from what they've
learned
are you just are you like are you just
like binge watching something are you
just collecting data or hey I watched
this over some of my video pause let me
go apply what I learned from what I just
learned from that you know I mean I just
watched maybe some other video even from
you guys like you know I listened to the
great 3M podcast right now you have some
choices like hey let me pause this let
me try to see what they're talking about
right or do you just keep going on and
on are you just consuming data consuming
spiritual knowledge like it's
entertainment or are you listening to
your favorite speaker and you got that
thing from The Tick Tock from the short
from wherever you consumed and now
you're gonna go apply it you know
because that Hadith applies to this as
well too so I'm asking to all those true
Seekers of knowledge right are you
applying what you're learning or are you
just binge watching and consuming about
your entertainment has your Dean just
become entertainment
survive this is where the intention is
the most important
that you see intention to use it trying
to learn something okay the intentions
to learn that you said you shouldn't be
watching like 20 something videos all
you need is one you might not even need
the entire one you might only need like
the first five ten seconds like the
first five ten seconds you might be
picking up that phone and you got your
answer you might as well put that phone
back down and apply it you know there's
so many videos I've watched but
immediately I paused it and I just like
immediately went on the tangent about
what I just learned right there and I
never even got attention that's great
have you ever read a book where it was
so promising and the book was so
captivating right that you just stopped
over there you were reflecting on
thinking about it and then you start to
supply what you were learning in that
book so far in that moment and you never
even got a chance to finish it that's
what true like application of knowledge
looks like where you're just so excited
to apply what you've learned that you
don't have time and if that's how you
thought how could you really burn out
you know like I the we are advised the
opposite in a way because because Allah
is going to question us about all the
knowledge that we learned but didn't act
on think about that that knowledge that
you that you're you're acquiring to
testify for you're against you on the
day of judgment what's the point of
knowing so much more when you're not
applying even the little that you know
and that's something that Allah will
question us that we had that we didn't
apply so like why is it that we just
want to consume consume consume like are
we just doing it for the sake again
entertainment or do we really want to
apply because if you are pausing and
slowing down and not being extreme right
how can you get burnt out it's such a
nice Rhythm it's Harmony you know you're
burning out because you are not in
Balance you understand that's why the
burnout is happening because in whatever
field of your life because you're not
you're not really balanced and
everyone's balance looks different yeah
actually you know Allah says in the
Quran just to back up your point he
talks about the people you know
especially the scholars who of you know
the memorized book so they have books
they have the knowledge they don't do
anything they know what Allah calls them
he says they're like donkeys carrying
books wow
literally they're like donkeys caring my
teacher uses a much nicer example he
says it's like a hard drive right that's
just lame all these files on it but
Allah himself says they're like donkey
scaring books
if Allah is not afraid to use that kind
of example then we shouldn't be either
so are you a donkey carrying books or
are you mother to the viewers are you a
doctor a donkey no for real though
that's that's that's amazing to think
about because a lot of us again wants to
be these consumers and the burnout
happens when you're not in Balance
that's what I'm really thinking about
right now
you know just saying something like that
and this just applies to anything
because if you look at even the
alignment of your car wheels right if
you look at the threads of the wheels
and if one side is like rubbing a little
bit more and or look at the bottom of
your sneaker right in the back of it
some people's like side heels or like a
little bit more it shows the reason is
burning out right it's because too much
weight is coming on one side and the way
you walk with your heel and just your
alignments overall and the really cool
thing about Alberta and I think burnouts
are amazing because it's an indicator to
you that something's wrong you
understand and you could it's it's just
a message any bad feeling any negative
emotion is a message to you that
something needs to get fixed now you
could take it as oh my God my day is so
bad or some you gotta interpret it make
a new meaning that hey something's off
let me go inspect what's wrong so maybe
you go to a chiropractor you see that
hey maybe my alignments a little bit off
how do I walk more correctly you check
the car out hey your family could have
been in danger right you fix the car out
when you start feeling spiritual burnout
or any type of burnout within that
matter right instead of running away
from that feeling because that makes it
worse you run away from the field of
learner like ah this anxiety you you
push away all these emotions instead
like explore that emotion a little bit
more and find out what is the message
that you've got to learn one message is
that you've got to balance things out a
little better and every once like I said
balance looks different
always I want to use the example of one
you helped us set up this lighting there
okay what did you do what did you start
with
oh you're asking me yeah oh yeah I don't
know about this do you okay uh we we
turned off all the lights yeah so you
started with everything yes I think you
started with the back yeah building
blocks you built it little by little by
little and things started to come
together and now we have a nice living
room so your life is kind of like that
you have to start with what's most
important what's urgent find a good
balance find a good uh you know amount
of time you can commit to a good amount
of effort and give it to them and then
add school to that and then add organize
it add whatever this is assuming that
Dean is the first thing yeah that's the
most important you know family and then
work in school and we find a good
balance bro and I just think of all you
just said look how beautiful it is right
when you get burnt out what happens you
start doing everything yes right so it's
like the same thing as like turning
everything off to like build it up from
there so it's like it's almost like
Allah's like
putting this inside of you like like you
said it's not it's not really bad it's
just letting you know hey there was
something wrong now you got to change it
I think that's that's that's a really
cool analogy today bro I'll show about
hello for real though because you know
this allows you to take control and in
one of our last podcast episodes she
talks about self-accountability and
Allah calls you to take account for
yourself you know
um uh it's it's interesting because
before it was like you the lights were
controlling you and how you wanted to
appear but now that we've made it all
blank you're controlling how much light
you want to be dictated right sometimes
we get all this beautiful equipment and
we don't know what to do with this we
just think we have to use it all in one
shot even though it has no purpose of
use right and you could start getting
frustrated with the whole process but in
itself but we calmed it all down we shut
it down like you said all black screen
blank canvas and we just rearranged our
life a little bit a lot of people who
are dealing with anxiousness
um or or or like depression specifically
it's a call to action that's what these
emotions are you know the call to
actions that you need to reevaluate your
life and prioritize certain things right
things right it's your body's way of
calling you to take action about
whatever's happening so perhaps you need
to turn off the lights of your life a
little bit more right start fresh fresh
cannons okay and ask yourself what are
the most important things for me right
now okay my Dean let me start on my
theme first okay am I taking control of
everything but then you get over a month
but I gotta read more I got no no hold
on a second hold on remember consistent
small but consistent develop that a
little bit more okay right now you're
reading no Quran at all so thinking that
you're going to read a whole just is
kind of unrealistic right now for you
yeah I mean you're not reading any Quran
at all okay so is a page okay okay if
the page okay start there the page feels
good you want to go for the low hanging
fruit first really quickly I know you
know the the real the best part is above
the low-hanging fruit right but you got
to start somewhere and when you develop
that positive momentum by Allah's
permission it's going to become two
pages
and then three then four little Jews
inshallah but you don't just start like
you talk about workout analogies amongst
the trainers over here you don't just go
for that ego lift at first because not
only will you not accomplish anything
but you can hurt yourself forever and be
done like I don't want to go to the gym
because I slit the disc and now you have
psychological connotations
scares me I get trauma thinking about it
and all that versus those who have a
great positive relationship with the gym
it's because they have a nice sort of
relationship with them because they're
doing good and they see the progress and
all that and it's something good so
start from somewhere create a blank
canvas and make achievable goals low
hanging fruit and just create your life
to how you want to create it rather than
you know allowing the the stress of the
whole world to just dictate how you act
and that's the thing well have you seen
the graph of a one percent increase you
know more more effort every day and like
what happens over time editor you put it
up on the screen you know it's like one
percent Compound Effect and it's
exponential you literally see if you
were to be one percent better one
percent of it every day in a year what
would happen it's insane it's a lot
though it's kind of compounds right it
compounds if you look at like um like a
fossil or something like that right it's
from millions of years or so of
compounding it crushed it and it
preserved it at the same time so when
you get it out it's like a little stove
almost right there's something about
getting better every single day now I we
spoke about this in the car about what
is getting better looks like okay uh and
you know let's suppose the average
person gets up at eight a.m they don't
but let's suppose they do okay and you
decided it's easy to be average you you
are born average like everyone's born
average you know it's easy to be average
but above average right requires you to
do something a little bit more
unorthodoxist right let's suppose you
decided to wake up at seven one hour
earlier than everyone else right right
uh one hour what would happen is that if
you did this every single day right
every single day for seven days for
example right you would be seven hours
ahead of the person
that means you're seven and a half hours
ahead of accomplishments than that
person okay you take this for three
weeks all of a sudden you're 21 hours
nearly a whole day ahead of someone
you've accomplished and you're ahead if
this was a race you're one more day
ahead of that person and if you could
keep compounding this you'll be years
ahead of people before you even know it
you get me but it came from a very small
change right which was not one hour so
ask I'm encouraging myself and everyone
else right ask yourself what's that one
tiny change that you can make in your
life that can make a huge difference not
right now right but that curve
eventually will be skyrocketing up while
everyone else is like sort of flat lies
Hobby
he's uh
that sounds familiar too I don't know I
don't know I don't know anything but can
I tell you the story about you UFC by
the way I know nothing about UFC I know
nothing about it I'll tell you I'll tell
you a funny story though I don't know if
I've told you this before I haven't
really shared this it's a fun one I
think I think the viewers at home like
this as well too so
um I've tried this was in December I was
traveling no no December like February
and we're at the TSA line in JFK right
and um you know that line is just you
know crazy you know there's Loops after
Loops have to do so we're there and you
know I'm in like my foe I have a goofy
on or whatever I have on like you know
but it's like clearly I'm a Muslim my
sister is a hijab I'm doing live so we
see each other you know it's happening
in the line there's like two brothers
who just look at us they see this and
it gave us like that Muslim look you
know you look at somebody though yeah oh
oh
you know one of those type of looks
right and they were like these two like
Russian dude kind of looking people I
don't know but they were like you know
you can tell like they're sort of
European Russian you could just tell
like it's like that right and one dude's
face was just beaten up you know it just
Brews you could tell like they just came
out of War right and uh they had like
like these UFC shirts on stuff like that
okay but mind you I know nothing about
UFC at all like the only sport I know is
like basketball
yeah yeah but I don't really know it
like that you know um and uh that's
about it right even in soccer football
right like I don't know nothing about it
like I know some major players but I
wouldn't be able to tell you who's on
that team beside I don't even know what
team they play for but I know them you
know but anyways right so we keep seeing
each other and you know eventually we
just get cool because we just keep
looping and seeing each other each time
right and every time we bump into each
other again when we cross we're just
saying something to each other and all
that sort of stuff and they're like oh
we already had a chance I hope we're
going to override all that she's like oh
you know they're like oh mashallah
okay and then we keep going
um and then eventually they let our line
in first and we cross the head of them
because they were ahead of us right and
I'm like see guys look how large is open
the door before you and they laughed
about it whatever right come to find out
we have the same gate like we were right
there for the gate and stuff like that
so I'm there at the gate and I see the
two brothers coming and everything
and um it's time to pray and these dudes
ready to pray I'm like oh let's pray
together everybody all right let's go
straight together so one of the brothers
goes and he changes this will do he
prays everything
and in the meantime we're just like
chatting in just talking to each other
and all that sort of
you know uh we go about it and say hey
what do you do and all that listen
ing
I started saying what I do and I said
are you guys fired
yeah we fight uh I said oh my God I know
nothing about fighting except like
khabib right you know like like that's
the only fighter I know right he's like
oh yeah you know that's my brother I
said oh like I thought he saw like
brother in Islam kind of thing
no listen Okay so so it's it's like my
brother and son so I said because I
asked them to like are you guys others
he said yeah no that's my brother in
Islam I said oh so when he said oh oh
like oh like that's my brother used to
be the same thing she's like okay right
so me and this brother no no the second
brother me and his brother pray together
and we finished praying and all that
sort of stuff and uh we exchanged
information and all that sort of stuff
said I said hey buddy what's your name
he said oh my name is Islam I said I
said oh I sound like the religion he's
like yeah like the religion we just
laugh about it and all that's right
now it's boarding time and he's going
let's go I said no no I'm on the other
way oh okay never mind and I said how
did we say she's like listen just hit me
up message me on Instagram that's okay
cool so uh I he said uh take down my
thing so I said okay cool uh what's
what's your hand though he said Islam I
said Islam I see that dot it's a DOT
someone else whoa what do you saying he
said right and he just types it all in
he said okay this is me it's not like
okay
no problem I said okay bro sound like a
I'm walking back and look at my phone
like who what what is this you know
verified takes four million followers
I'm like what's happening over here and
it turned out to be Islam I think you
guys know
I don't know yeah
sorry to say and maybe you guys could
verify and uh you end up following back
and everything I don't even know I don't
even know yeah you just did that if you
message on Instagram and everything so
yeah
I don't think he's his brother
yeah but that's pretty cool I just
wanted to share that I don't know I
thought that was a cool story to share
but yeah
you might like it yeah but I met his
brother some but the coolest thing was I
think that even they recognized it
because oh look you guys much A lot of
people are growing with the podcast so
people recognize you guys too and you
know a lot of people probably like
geeked out to some degree as well too
and I think that what they appreciated
was that
I didn't really I don't even know I just
waited to pray with them and I was going
to be on my way I knew nothing about
them and I didn't care I just wanted to
pray and I didn't do that and it turned
out to be they turned out to be that
freaking Islam like these major UFC and
the other brother
um he's another UFC fighter as well too
but I'm sorry I can't really say
right you know but but may Allah bless
them but I don't know why we were
talking about this but I just had to
mention that story sorry well that was a
good attention that was a good attention
all right let me let me go back to it
I'm sorry about that I don't know it's a
good story you met him but
we had him on the podcast he's into
philosophy of psychology and and
basically brother for us when he was in
the jewelry podcast right he made this
this side tangent away from the real me
of the podcast and he was talking about
how to train smarter how to work out
smarter I think you guys can search it
up if you want it's like a short clip
from the actual podcast on Joe Rogan and
philosophy goes into like the philosophy
of like or psychology of training and he
says when you train it could be MMA it
could be body wasn't gonna be anything
there's there's this level where you've
trained just enough to make games but
you haven't exceeded your mark in
Victory it's not like you're exhausted
you haven't had that fatigue or
something yet you haven't hit that point
where you're gonna go home and you're
gonna go oh I don't want to train for
like a week and he said when you hit
that Mark stop
that way you can go again tomorrow he
said there's people that go to the gym
for three hours that they don't go for
like another week and he says for him
he'd rather go like 45 minutes per day
and if you're 457 it's way more than
three hours so just like you said the
month end of the year how many more
hours or even weeks ahead of the curve
is he compared to someone that just goes
all in and it brings up
and at the end of the day when you look
at like muscles like physiology to gain
like in gains it all depends on volume
the biggest component as well I mean how
much are you doing not how heavy you are
and not frequency anything but volume
when you look at volume to max it up I
would rather do a little bit or
consistently do it 360 fun days yeah but
so when you when you really put two and
two together bro it makes sense that
when the power saw something to make
sure that you know the best of Deeds or
or about love speeds that are small or
consistent ax Pro small consistent Deeds
prevent burnout think about that right
so small consistent these prevents
burning off because of what you just
said bro because if you are doing
something consistently you're in flow
you're balanced you get me but if you
start doing more than what you can
handle and I think that there's even
that is a next meeting because sometimes
you should lift more right because
you've got to tear that muscle apart so
you can start rebuilding it again right
so we're not saying to always do the
tiniest to bare minimum we're not saying
that but what we're saying is to get in
that Rhythm especially at first and then
you add another weight to it so that you
can grow I mean that's what that's what
I brought at the end of the day if you
really think about it philosopher said
not to go to intensity but he mentioned
a strong point that intensity entails
that it cannot be done consistently with
high frequency because if you were if
you were going to go 100 every day how
does that even make sense if you want
100 today you can't go 100 so then
you're not really going 100 so intensity
means it's only every now and then so
you're saying when you're in off season
yeah sure when it's time like it's
coming it's like you know the mask is
going to be like within a month or
within a few weeks then you can start
off the intensity every day or more
frequently but in in off season you
shouldn't be going to intensity or
failure of fatigue you should be sure to
wearable once a week or once a month
maximum you know you you mentioned
something about you know even recovery
for example going back to that working
out analogy even recovery is a part of
the training right even recovery is part
of training to build that muscle to
where you need to get to those games
here
um
if you're not
balanced with the recovery as well
you're not going to have the same type
of feelings you need to be balanced by
Ultra recovery so like you mentioned bro
about the scholars who the scholar who
would also listen to some entertainment
you know at the same time that's a part
of the balance process that prevents
burning out so if all you do is study
study study study all the time and you
have no leisure time right to relax the
mind so it could process a little bit I
mean even babies right why do they sleep
so much it's because they're processing
all the information that they had
because at night time is when their
brain is truly working right it's really
working hard so they can process
everything as well too that's their
balance that's how they have to maintain
balance so asking everyone listeners
ourselves over here as well too even
with this podcast so let's be real this
could be draining this could like this
whole podcast uploading content and all
the content creators out there if
someone is listening is a content
creator it's extremely overwhelming it's
it could it could cause you to burn out
you know it could cause your burnout and
there's so many people who say that I
need them I need to take a break you
know the reason you're taking a break
from it is because you were you were
working on those RPMs were too high you
know the archives rather than being
smooth and consistent you know you were
just doing more than you should have
done and consistent doesn't mean upload
every day or create something every
single day consistency means that you're
working towards your goal every single
day that doesn't mean that it's getting
uploaded right it doesn't mean it's
getting creative but you're getting
closer and closer to that step so it's
just about bite-sized goals that you can
just you know get that dopamine Rush by
saying ah got it done I mean it you know
there's something about putting a check
a mark next to that box because it feels
good that you've done something so
basically what you're saying if you want
to finish reciting the Quran you're not
going to recite the Quran entirely
interest every day but you're going to
read x amount every day every day with
the intention to finish it so that yeah
even if you dive in that process Allah
would reward you as if you did finish it
you get it because he knew your
intentions the whole entire time you
know so having that Medium that balance
because Islam is a religion of balance
it's not about extremes if you're if you
are practicing Islam or anything else
with an extreme you're doing it wrong
you're practicing your faith wrong
you're studying wrong you're working
wrong you're with your family wrong it
has to be a balance and you have to
strike that balance out what's a great
way to do that turn off all the like
start fresh with that canvas and just
start prioritizing what matters the most
to you it should be a lot of your family
everything else is just an option Allah
and your family are the number one
priorities that you should have right
and to those who are single what does
that mean for family your mother your
your siblings your dad like you know
your family that should be a priority
Allah and your family should be the
priority everything else doesn't matter
why are you at the dinner table on your
phone talking to people who don't matter
they're not here they're not here
they're not with you they're not you
know they're not good they haven't they
work they don't matter as much as the
people in real life matter with you
don't tell me that your mom is talking
to and you're looking at the phone don't
tell me your dad is talking to you he
calls you or your mom calls you yeah
yeah yes okay bye don't tell me that the
people you're with are more important
than that lady who called you on the
phone don't tell me that you're
practicing it wrong you're not
respecting your mom enough like if
you're texting more people than you are
and you look at your relationship with
your mom it's all the way at the bottom
like that like come on you really have
to prioritize your life because we spoke
about this one day one day that lady
won't be around one day you're going to
be giving a hustle to your dad that's
the fact
you're gonna give a whistle to your dad
that's a fact that's gonna happen so why
are you waiting to touch their cold
corpse before you realize how much
regret you have forgot telling you love
them or whatever you know I mean like
don't do that to yourselves go and tell
your parents tell them you love them
prioritize them while they're in your
life right now prioritize Allah
prioritize you know the people who
matter the most in your life because
that Tick Tock is still going to be
there that PS5 that Call of Duty that
FIFA the NBA 2K all that stuff is still
going to be there but obeying your mom
when she said hey you know take out the
garbage or when your sister say hey I
need to move the car can you clear the
driveway that response is something that
that means more than anything else that
you're doing right now inspires bro it
makes me reflect a lot of man because in
today's thing is we're actually taught
like all purpose first purpose first
purpose first and it's like well now you
become Muslim or you're born Muslim like
and you come back to the dean you
understand a place of Love first but
then now now that you know there's a
love first now you still have the whole
thing in society being caused like all
purpose first at least for men you know
it's all like oh we need to have this
focus and while I I do agree to a very
large system that we need to have
something that we're working towards
that we can use to provide a means for
our family and for ourselves
we shouldn't be living to work
we should be working to live you know
like working so that we have more time
with those that we love most
I think that's very important
step into work or working with us yeah
yeah and you'll find a lot of these
things overlap especially when you go on
that order of Islam family working that
stuff because if you look at this time
it actually gives right here now gives
priority to your family so if you
actually are practicing a Muslim right
you're a practicing Muslim you'll find
that I need to be there for my parents
for my children for my wife my brothers
and sisters I need to actually maintain
that kinship with all of them and that's
when I prior to the Sam that's what
happens I had to take care of my family
that means I actually have to work out
so now I'm going to go to work and it
kind of you'll find these things
actually work
and some kind of congruent match it's a
holistic thing putting Allah first
naturally gets all the other Affairs 100
100 and then you'll actually realize
there's a time for this in the time for
that because it stands as the time for
this in time for that right you'll
you'll find that there's a time where I
need to be alone and pray myself by
myself and read Quran by myself and
reply maybe it's only 20 minutes maybe
it's only half an hour and you'll find
there's a time to be alone with your
wife and the time to be with your kids
together I mean every individual kid
about himself it was the time to get
them again from time to be certain
things and there's a time to go and work
and make money for your family and
provide for them
boy
I wanted to share these examples okay so
um before I begin with some I was the
exact thing that you just mentioned or I
would be with my mom but I wasn't with I
was
messaging friends and messaging
you know
right and we're always playing video
games or something like that right then
I became Muslim and then or actually
before I became Muslim understood
purpose so then it's like man it's
always for me like messaging a whole
bunch of people walking with it now me
just not being with a functional purpose
right then I became Muslim I was like oh
Allah first okay I do need it for Allah
suffering a lot first but then anytime
I'm with my mom I'm like just basically
pushing to the side because I'm thinking
to myself
learn more about this time but there's
some place where right so then this is
happening this is happening and then I
start getting to the point where
um I realized my mom needs help you know
I was in Thailand and allowed me a very
clear to me like look it's your time to
leave Thailand but as much as I wanted
to sing Talent like allow me to very
feel like it's unbelief it's time to
help my mama and I come to I come to the
US again to like come on Mama and I'm
thinking myself
back in this situation to help
financially let's be the man right so
I'm like doing this I'm like full on my
purpose and then my mom's like he's like
kind of breaking down my blister but
she's breaking down in a way while I was
like I literally I was like
why why are you saying this like I'm
literally
here I came from Thailand like um I'm
with you like I'm I'm providing and I'm
doing all this like why do you even feel
like that she's like
I need you here I don't need you to pay
so this is
that I was like oh like that hit me like
it hurt bro like I'm getting like two
dragons like that hurt because like as a
man I was thinking like I had to provide
this way when all my mom wanted was just
like leaving my attention my energy bro
like the presence bro like that's
okay family first or family it's like
people think women but not just women
but family but especially your older bro
people think they just want one thing at
a time gross pleasing a woman satisfying
a woman is so much different than for
women treating men but we're talking
about this in the court a lot of people
don't just want one thing and this kind
of ties into the whole love language
thing we're talking about sometimes
people just want time from you quality
time undivided time not you on your
foreign
you know I was doing
I was doing this right this right and
you really have to ask yourself like if
you're doing it for the sake of Allah
whether someone appreciates it or not it
doesn't matter right you do the same old
box put the Eyes involved there's a lot
of ego involved right like I gotta be
the man I got to do this and when she
said that it just took away your your
evil immediately right immediately it
just stripped you of it like that's not
what she wants she wanted this right and
that's something we got to remember a
lot of times like our family they just
want you they just want quality time
with you they don't want you to buy them
and take these on holidays and all that
sort of stuff those are in my opinion A
lot of times distractions from a real
problem you know it's a distraction
because you're trying to buy Your Love
by your quality time and sometimes you
just go for a walk cool man it's cool
like you guys just want to spend time
together but
you just again everyone's balance is a
little different you know everyone is
balancing differently but you have to
start somewhere you have to realize that
you know priorities reprioritizing your
life and making sure that Allah is the
top of the priority will help it's like
you know when the campus is black
where did we start first you start with
Allah you start with your relation with
Allah because a lot of people might be
wondering okay SQ three Muslims it
sounds really good where do I start to
regain my balance start with your
relationship with Allah because it's
Allah who's going to put barakah and
everything else for you you know so like
all those things that are burning you
out why are you giving it so much
importance when you can just call out to
the one who can put blessings in that
thing that's causing you to burn out
like just ask Allah to show you the way
to perform that work show me the way and
you know even if your marriage and you
know maybe perhaps your husband isn't
the way you want it to be right or
that's good for you or your wife isn't
the way you want her to be or that's
good for you oh Allah make them good for
me have you thought of that right me are
so you know Hellbound on trying to
change them why are you trying to change
them ask the owner of the heart to turn
their heart why are you why am I trying
to do that remove the eye from your
language and from your vocabulary and
just turn to Allah stop thinking that I
have something to do with it I have
nothing to do with it it's all a lot you
know and you're asking me this question
like aren't you worried about like your
daughter says like the world the living
is like I might be worried but you know
when they go out to school I have no
control over that so oh Allah take care
of my daughters oh Allah take care of my
children take care of my family Allah
I'm not home Allah be there with them be
there watch over them Allah take care of
them that that way you're developing
more to walk with your relationship with
Allah as well too so those are like
extra hacks for people to develop better
connections so let's go into that how do
you maintain and strike that balance
with your family person because well
being a social figure being an
influencer having a YouTube channel
having X Y I see all of these things
that you're trying to get a project
exams up much longer guys Linked In the
description guys come on all this stuff
that you're doing martial arts about it
I'm going for but
how are you doing this and still giving
your family time I want some it's in a
quiet place to learn the art but we talk
about this thing yeah something about
unavailable what were you saying
so okay so you're asking me how do I
strike that balance or anything like
that I think before I was terrible at it
I still not good at it I just want to be
clear may Allah make me better but I
don't know I don't have the answer and I
don't want to front like I do have the
answers all I know is I've messed up a
lot and I have the scars to remember I
have those fights with my wife in
relationships but I have those missed
moments my daughters to prove it I have
those you know late nights in the lab
try to upload a video to prove it you
know I have those uh those uh times I've
missed my my daughter uh going to bed or
besiding Quran to them while they're
going to bed something to prove it you
know so I'm not here to tell you that I
have those answers because I don't have
those answers but one thing
alhamdulillah that Allah has allowed we
need to do
um is take one thing at a time I think
that when you do too many things at once
you're unable to really do justice to
any one thing so again just starting off
from somewhere and just giving it a lot
more attention so you're right
um when you do so many things naturally
one thing is going to suffer it's it's
common law that's going to happen
something is going to take effect
something is going to mess up but again
I think that I've learned from all those
mess-ups for example
when I started doing my daily uploads
because once upon a time that I was
uploading every single day and honestly
it put me off from even wanting to do
YouTube like it was just like I remember
I remember once upon a time when all I
did was make sure that I needed to be
the first one to upload something about
it right I needed to be the first one oh
shoot Logan Paul said something about
God oh God I'll make a video yeah but
babe you were about to go do something I
know babe but I gotta do this
bro I gotta I gotta talk about this oh
they just they just did something about
oh they did the same device on I gotta
go make a video about it you know I
gotta go do all these things about it
and it was taken away from the quality
of my life it was taking away from the
quality of my content and it just it
became like this rush job that I started
to do and the biggest thing that I feel
like I took away from was my sincerity
and my Mia of why because before you
touch before you press record you should
have some neon sincerity and look only
online knows what the Trulia is right I
can sit here and tell you it's to inform
people is to give downwards to tell
people about what's happening and all
that sort of stuff but if I'm being
honest with myself and may Allah Purify
Me the other part of the Nia also well
so I could be the first one to do it I'm
competing amongst other Muslim YouTubers
right because oh I know damn that
YouTuber is going to talk about it first
then who's going to want to watch my
video because I need to do the I gotta
to be the breaking news person like that
like what is this drama learning what is
this you know like what is this like is
this Islamic is this what I'm doing now
is this what it comes down to like I
just got to make the first video about
it oh shoot they said something about
and shout out to more power to you if
you're doing those things I'll talk
about myself obviously right and you
know this brings me to the point of when
you know the the people will be brought
from Allah on the day of judgment and it
will be the Martyr
and you know you know he he died for the
same well he's gonna say you know what
have you done now you know I went for
Jihad Feast to be alive died for you
online I fought for you and all that and
then Allah is going to tell them you've
lied you did it so that you could be the
whole town hero you did it so that
people could say what a strong and brave
Warrior he was it was not accepted
health
Hellfire right a person a scholar right
who who of someone who memorized Quran
or uh learned right that Dean got the
knowledge right what did you do what did
you do I I I saw knowledge for you Allah
you've lied you did it so that people
can say you're educated
he did it some people could say doctor
that title you did it so you could get
one of those marks on your head that's
why you were praying you were really
praying you were trying to do it for a
show only Allah knows that Nia you
understand and that's what I had to
realize that Not only was I burning out
in that process of I gotta do I gotta do
I gotta do it it made me become someone
I'm not and I it's there's so many
people out there whenever there's
something because they're searching for
Content you guys are content creators
right sometimes you know that you're
thinking about content like you know
what should we post about what should we
do about what should it becomes very
tedious and difficult at times you know
and these people are addicted all the
time so oh shoot let me talk about LGBT
let me just talk about it let me just
talk about this new celebrity did
something let me talk about them they're
creating content all the time about
these things and look may Allah reward
them okay I don't want someone to think
that I'm trying to throw Subs at
anything it's not like it's not like
that it works for you cool I'm talking
about my experience I was doing this
thing and I just don't think that that
was the right way to do it for me and it
caused me to get burned out and I just I
had to take step back but the good thing
about taking a step back it's not a bad
thing burnouts aren't a bad thing it
showed me that I'm not doing something
correct now alhamdulillah I feel like I
found a really good balance between
things where I upload what I want to
upload I don't it's not like when I'm
between two uploads I'm not doing
anything no I'm actually trying to
perfect that upload that you're about to
see and I just drop it when I'm ready to
drop it you know I and it's cool like I
just move on my own speed I move at my
own time and I just move with better
intentions and better Mia now I don't
want to just post for posting anymore
and you know shout out to all those
people who are watching my content every
single day uploads but it was taking a
toll on me you know it was at first it
was a lot of fun a lot of fun like I
just do it I wasn't even editing someone
goes back to the videos I don't even
edit them I just like posted wrong
exactly out the camera how it is that's
that's done but there were times where I
was just talking about jumping on the
bandwagon of whatever is hot you know
because that's a great technique let's
be serious over here right that's a
algorithm technique right where you talk
about that trending topic right oh shoot
Will Smith took a sloppy slap them okay
how can I make a video about that within
Islam and all that
okay
it's not it's not it's not it's not it's
not it's not that like you know light
year came out with it like how do I make
a thing about that like you know
whatever it might be like there's
YouTubers who do that and I think that
that's needed that's needed like I don't
think there's gonna be so many people
upset with me like I'm not trying to
Target anyone when I was doing that it
took me away from the sincerity it just
made me feel like I was on high alert
all the time you know about some amazing
article that I need to make a video
about like oh
[ __ ] and all that sort of stuff yeah you
know people are are you know being
harmed in Kashmir and no one's really
talking about that right the rohingyan
refugees are still in Bangladesh they
want to talk about that because it's not
that trending of a topic right so where
did my sincerity really really lie like
did it lie with the algorithm or about
trendy topics try to make like these
clickbaity things that people are going
to watch or is this really to help the
amount is it really am I trying to do
that you know and at first I feel like I
was not that I wasn't I believe there is
sincerity in that but I just haven't
really take a step back from all those
things so if you're asking how did I do
this I don't know how am I doing all
that stuff
I I just take my time with it bro I
don't think that you know people might
be saying okay you've been selling this
um where's the school in Palestine
didn't even know what it takes to build
a school in Palestine like I'm doing it
I'm doing like a million things it's
happening when it happens keep making
Dua for each other let's stay sincere
let's stay in the course and you know
just be patient with things it'll work
out when it works out so that's that's
working for me right I just take my time
with it
take that time
because we've already internalized it
and to us it's kind of like okay yeah
but like when we say it remember how I
told you like we say something and like
you you could want to tell us something
but we're gonna pick up from that
whatever we need is kick out from you
know we may have not even picked up the
thing that you wanted us to pick up on
but we picked up and then a lot I'll use
me to provide more beneficial knowledge
to people I mean he used you guys in
this platform and all the guys out there
you know I I think that's one thing that
really clicked with me that changed me
and this is the conversation I have in
my life because when I was doing this
going back to that point of daily
uploads or talking about this topic or
that topic that was trendy or whatever
you know it comes with expectations I
didn't get the view
that's problematic man that's really
problematic like I needed to understand
why did that hurt so much why did it
hurt that my view didn't get it you know
like you know why did it hurt so much
that that didn't get a view why is that
bothering me so much and I realized I'm
putting so much effort into it
investment into it whether that be time
or whether it be buying something for a
video and my wife had to this is why I
tell you guys about the wife's thing
guys like you know I know what a month
says you know one person else is married
over here and mashallah other brothers
are getting married very soon
and you know um it it's it's something
you guys can remember when you have the
companion it can talk you off the edge
and talk you off that ledge because you
just want to quit you're like you know
I'm done with everything I don't want to
post nothing and she's like
and this is where the hell you you give
dawa you're gonna die
that's what you are you're a diet you're
doing this you're saying Allah you're
servant of Allah and you know when I
started taking on that identity then it
just didn't matter it just didn't matter
if you watched it or not you just it
just didn't matter it still doesn't
matter to me and every time it may Allah
keep be more sincere with this as well
through every time when I upload I have
a ritual now the ritual is you know it
sounds funny but you know having fresh
will do anytime before I make you know
I'll do an upload and
um
you know
keep me content make me content with the
risk that you give this risk doesn't
mean money right this is the Baraka it's
the goodness it's just all forms of
goodness that comes from that
um and I just ask a lot to make me
content with it
ever since I've been doing that whatever
I get from this I'm happy with it like I
just feel happier it feels like there's
more blessings in it and I get geeked
out now if I get more views than I'm
expected to and it's performing better
than it does and I'm just like I'm just
so much more grateful for you I'm so
much more grateful now rather than I
posted it I'm checking it I'm refreshing
it I'm like that can't be right come on
and I'm gonna say why isn't it happening
now I'm just getting beat I'm like yo
you know because I have no expectations
now I'm I'm content I'm content I've
left it to Allah I'm content and I'm
asking Allah Allah utilize this to
spread your deed utilize this utilize it
being utilize this platform that you've
given me to spread your lead you know
utilize these things a lot utilize me to
spread your religion Allah make this
religion this religion is going to be
successful online utilize me to help
make it successful you know and asking
Allah to be a part of it you know just
renewing my intentions with each video
I'm uploading so someone might want to
ask you you need to upload more and
people tell me that now versus when it's
so funny because I said upload
everything now people tell me you should
upload more and if you're wondering why
I haven't uploaded in so long it's
because between one upload and the other
what's what's happening is not only is
the video being edited by my intentions
are being renewed and it takes time for
me it takes time and I just need to take
my time renew the upload renew the
intentions with the new upload and take
it from there
before you end off I don't want to come
online because I think you obviously
summer is a really beautiful especially
from your experience
um well I do want to comment on is the
whole kind of balancing more so the
family aspect of it
no I'm in a position where you know I
see myself as
you know responsible for my family no
I'm not talking about money I'm talking
about everywhere the world the
development done feeling loved and
appreciating all that stuff so I feel
like I've learned a lot so far I've
picked up on a lot of things online
I think a good way to summarize it is
it's not about doing a lot it's not it's
not about doing big things it's about
doing the right things when it comes to
people these are people these are human
beings right you also with my working
with human beings you can text someone
you know three days in a row
but it might not mean as much as giving
them a call once a week you know does
that call the intimacy I'm talking about
intimacy like in a romantic way but that
intimate talk you're gonna talk with
your brother right you're just
interested in something like you're
close to somebody right so you can have
that with anyone but it's just a matter
of doing it the right way imagine
playing chess right in chess you don't
just want to move a lot of pieces you
know you don't want to move you know you
don't want like big moves like I'm gonna
move the queen on the other side of the
board but you want to make the red ones
right and think about you know doing
imagine you got your wife like 10 gifts
but none of them were things that she
has used for more likes at all imagine
you especially with women like they have
a very specific aesthetic very specific
fashion sense and you get them 10 items
of clothing that is so far away from
their sense of fashion they would
honestly feel a little upset and if they
got if they didn't appreciate it you'd
feel upset you in return right but
that's that's the beauty of doing
something for the sake of Allah if you
kept them the best in your mind when you
did that action Allah has already
rewarded you whether they appreciate it
or not it doesn't matter yeah because
Allah will reward you and if they are
displeased with it you turn to Allah you
don't get mad at them you don't have a
fight with them you turn to Allah and
say online but if you know I did this
for your sake never work before that
right and you know this goes to the
story of The Men Who were trapped inside
the cave and the boulder came in front
of it right and every man told a story
about what they did and they said oh
Allah if I did that for your sake remove
the Rock and everyone's Rock moved a
little bit right so if you did something
for someone and you did it for the sake
of Allah then it doesn't matter if they
appreciate it or not as human beings
obviously we like the gratification we
like that and there's nothing wrong with
that like I understand that as someone
who fears Allah they need to also
respond to say hey let's start with
appreciating the fact they did that
right like I'm sure they deserve someone
to remind them like hey like don't do
that and Allah might be upset with them
for doing that and I think a good person
would recognize that yo I need to like
really be appreciative of this as well
too you know and it reminds me of one of
the first fights I got into my wife very
very first fight right and uh this is
when we were first like talking and
um we had gotten our Anaconda but she
was still in the UK and also in the
United States right and um
I had gotten her something that I
thought that she was like it was a pair
of like like some type of shoes and a
guide for her and and she didn't like it
at all like I was so geeked to like got
it because I secretly got her shoe size
I did all these things you know and I
went all around it got it ordered from
the UK sent over to her from her
favorite shop and this and that and she
got it she was just like oh yeah it's oh
yeah you know it's not even I can't wear
shoes like this because this is
and I remember I was at work when this
happened I was just so upset bro honest
to God and you know shaytan comes to you
even more right you know she was in
respect you now we need to do later on
you know and I was just so so upset
about it and I spoke to her about this
like yo I did this for you you don't
even consider what I had to go through
to do this and then she was just like
listen I didn't mean it like that it's
just I can't wear these type of shoes
and all that sort of stuff
and that put like a really bitter taste
in my mouth at that time
if I could go back and redo that again
right
I would have handled it completely
different I would have realized that hey
look I did this for the sake of Allah
ain't no problem at all there's no words
babe there's a receipt inside of it send
it back and get the one that you want I
love you it doesn't matter right because
if I did it for the sake of Allah and
she's communicating if she didn't like
them just have her take care of it right
I still got the book report from it I
still got the reward from it right yeah
I didn't get the fact that she likes
that or whatever but you know what's
better that or this immature aspect that
you're just gonna fight with her and do
that and show a really ugly side of
yourself as well too because I've
changed since then you know and I
remember when I was in Saudi and I had
to get my wife
you know something a gift and you know I
was afraid to get her something because
I'm like you know I know she's kind of
picky with it and I spoke to my wife I'm
like hey I want to get you something I'm
going to show what you might like and I
learned to maybe consult her a little
bit more of the guests and she told me
she's like I'm not that same person that
you gave the shoes to before you get me
anything out of it right there's a
majority process that everyone has to go
through you know there's a majority
process that we all have to go through
and I had to go through that and she had
to go for that as well too it's all
about growing and getting closer to
Allah so like you know like I I just
think that when you do something with
the sake of a lot and you hold the door
for someone and they don't say thank you
you know the password you're like you're
welcome passive aggressively you know
it's not gonna be welcome no because you
did this for the sake of Allah you did
it for the sake of Allah you know and if
they say thank you it doesn't matter
Allah is a Shakur right they spoke about
this Allah
you know he's already showing you the
gratitude for that act by giving you the
reward so what else do you want whether
they give your reward is not with youth
you know giving thanks to me right uh
you showing appreciation for me being
here it doesn't matter you know I did
this for the sake of Allah as well too
we all did it for the sake of Allah and
it does show that we do need to
appreciate each other so that doesn't
mean you don't know because you should
appreciation you should show
appreciation towards the creation of
Allah because when you appreciate other
people you're actually being shared
appreciation of Allah so you should go
out of your way to make the them feel
special you should do these things if
someone does something for you ask
yourself how can I do more for them you
look at the mall today that the the
Muslims they gave us the pizza right I
was playing around during the game with
the pizza but then I went and I gave you
the water right because like I just
wanted to share some appreciation it's
something small but you gave them the
water right you want to ask yourself how
can you show a preview and someone does
something for you I need to get them
back somehow you should start plotting
on how can you show them appreciation
when someone does something for you how
can you do more for them than they did
for you you know I mean
this
is awesome man I wish we could speak
forever girl but guys let us know if you
want to ask you back it's just so
fulfilling episode and discussion
growing I'm I'm truly appreciative for
for meeting us to I'm sure you saw as
well and just all the conversations that
we've had with him on and off camera and
just hold the limit amount of time that
we've done it this is our one this is
our second time interacting with the
first time was the podcast a year ago
and then the second time now is you come
here yes yes and you know I told you
about this like that year ago if you
guys check out that podcast that my
virtual person the virtual Mitch was you
know online you guys check that out so I
was like a complete I was at it I was in
a Crossroads of my life at that time
yeah I was at a full Crossroads of my
life guys I didn't know which direction
wrote about like I was I was burnt out I
I truly was just burnt out with
everything and again when you're burned
out you just want to quit everything
that you do in YouTube and all these
things was one of those things you know
I just wanted to quit and I just wanted
to stop everything like that as well and
that's just the chop of the straight
thought but the advice that I'm given is
the advice of the Prophet my house also
gave to the companions who were supposed
to be on that mountain of uh the amount
of where the archers were which was to
stay put if you're out there if you're
doing some work for the sake of Allah
stay put stop deviating stop thinking
you need to give up stay put stay
consistent and stay put do what you must
but just stay put just just stay where
you are and keep on doing it the shaytan
wants you to come down from that Hill he
wants you to come down stay put and I
was at this Crossroads because I didn't
know what I want to do with this so I
just felt like I was being like
everybody else when I was making those
videos about Logan Paul or whoever or
whatever that influencer did to that
influencer or that proceeded to that
person I was just becoming everyone else
I was just like every other person what
was unique about me nothing and I just
realized I need to be myself
Plano and how I need to do a little soul
searching I need to figure out what I
need to do I turn off the lights and I
just turned on what I wanted to turn on
and I just refigured some things out I
found out what are my best qualities
because when you try to be someone else
you lose yourself you got to be yourself
and a lot of times we don't know who we
are because we don't spend enough time
with ourselves spend time with yourself
figure out what are your likes your
dislikes and all that and just see where
your gifts are Allah has given us all a
gift let's apply those gifts let's just
recognize what those gifts are the
number one gift is to recognize who all
lies and that's the biggest gift that we
can have and we recognize that and but
Allah bless everyone who is listening
out there for real for real I appreciate
you guys doing wrestlers such like every
time I see you guys every time we meet
up for this podcast it brings a
different type of appreciation in my
life for you guys and I really
appreciate and loving you guys thank you
so much for the invite as always and uh
the realest podcast in the video for
sure
please one more time guys hit the links
in the description check out the
summertime project super important stuff
guys we all accepted from you and all of
us Allah I mean but that being said
Allah
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign